[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque jour il constate de nouvelles
pénuries dans les supermarchés
à trouver des pâtes voilà et puis comble
du luxe donc un petit goût de France
Mario Paul la ville est détruite à 80%
et le Kremlin avait exigé sa
capitulation dans un ultimatum au nom je
cite de la sauvegarde des habitants et
des infrastructures de la ville mais la
population est l'armée ukrainienne ne
lâche pas on nous impose un ultimatum et
on nous impose les points à remplir pour
mettre fin à la guerre ce n'est pas
correct et cela ne mènera nulle part
gourde montagne raconte il va voir
Madame condolesarai si vous vous
souvenez c'était ma conseillère
diplomatique de Georges Bush et elle lui
dit ah non à vous les Français ça suffit
déjà vous avez voulu arrêter l'entrée
des pays de l'Est Pologne et tout ça
dans l'OTAN vous allez pas nous empêcher
de faire rentrer l'Ukraine et la Géorgie
tout est dit
ni les habitants de Kiev ni même le
président ne les laisseront faire si on
avait fait appliquer les accords de mise
de si la France et l'Allemagne avaient
été suffisamment pugnace et suffisamment
convaincante si elle n'avait pas été
trop soumise aux États-Unis en clair et
que les États-Unis avaient renoncé à
cette méthode de la porte ouverte comme
on dit il n'y aurait pas eu cette guerre
hier André a dû creuser en pleine rue
une sépulture pour son propre voisin et
sa mère il avait 45 ans elle en avait 70
tous les deux sont morts d'une crise
cardiaque
pour vous pour chez volody merzuelinski
non j'ai pas d'admiration particulière
pour Monsieur Zelinski je crois juste
qu'il se comporte comme un chef d'État
voilà un exemple de la solidarité avec
l'Ukraine qui prend parfois des chemins
absurdes comme avec cette initiative
lancée par le ministre ukrainien de la
transition numérique une cagnotte pour
envoyer Vladimir Poutine sur Jupiter
l'entreprise française doivent continuer
à faire du commerce en Russie on peut
pas planter les entreprises françaises
il faut mettre des sanctions très fortes
sur beaucoup non très très peu très très
peu que Valérie Pécresse que Éric
Zemmour et que Emmanuel Macron nous
disent combien d'annuités dans leur
système parce que la cohérence voudrait
que ce soit 44 ou 45 annuités qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça et bien ça veut dire
qu'en réalité personne n'aura plus de
retraite à taux plein et que l'ensemble
des gens prendront leur retraite avec
une décote ça fera baisser l'intégralité
des pensions en moyenne de 10%. tant le
candidat Macron propose d'augmenter
l'âge de départ en retraite à 65 ans
c'est parce qu'en fait il veut gagner 9
milliards d'euros sur le dos des
retraités il explique comme ça
probablement c'est gagner des sous sur
le dos des travailleurs pour avoir ces 9
milliards d'euros qui vont lui permettre
de continuer à faire des cadeaux fiscaux
notamment au grand groupe vous percevez
toujours votre salaire de 5000 euros
nets mensuels affilié à votre poste de
président du parti du rassemblement
national pourquoi alors que vous l'avez
quitté je pense que j'apporte à mon
mouvement politique
quand même une visibilité une plus-value
on ne peut pas pendant 10 ans
faire l'impasse d'un débat démocratique
et donc il y a la nécessité aujourd'hui
d'avoir cet échange une campagne en tout
cas une campagne sans débat c'est
ensuite une élection avec un mandat peu
clair ça veut dire quand on parle de
légitimité ça veut dire que le débat qui
n'a pas lieu là où il n'y a pas de débat
démocratique et bien il y a des risques
dans la rue je pense que vous coûter
plus cher à votre chaîne que moi à mon
propre mouvement est-ce que vous
apportez plus à votre chaîne alors c'est
que moi
je ne dirai pas normal
mais au moins autant